[Music]
[Applause]
Hall of Famer Steve Young joining us the
former ESPN NFL analyst and former Super
Bowl MVP I thought of you the other day
well I think of you a lot of days but I
thought I thought of you watching
pukaa and the reason I thought of you is
because you played with Jerry Rice and
Jerry Rice had football speed it you
know it didn't translate to a 40-yard
dash but Jerry didn't get caught
pukaa doesn't have you know four five
speed or whatever but he has football
speed can you tell me like what is the
difference between a guy who just runs
40 and a 44 or a guy who runs 46 but
still he doesn't get caught yeah there's
a lot of guys that put a helmet on and
it messes up their like their
athleticism like they put the shoulder
pads the helmet they can put cleats on
they run around and it's like they're
not the athlete that they showed up you
know in shorts and uh most the time the
uniform creates a little bit of Havoc um
and slows you down a little bit and some
guys speed up or at least handle the
weight and the and the restrictions and
they actually get fat Jerry was that way
and I think puka you just you you've hit
it something that I think is really cool
because PUK is somebody that you do not
want to cover because he he's strong his
hand like he get he he's going to make
you miss and he's going to run by you
and you wonder why how and it's called
football speed and people always talk
about what is that you know I always
talk about the force you know the Star
Wars force like something you can't
really explain but it's a it's a talent
that when you put the uniform on you
actually get faster and Jerry was that
way yeah I agree and I I just feel that
way with puka nakua all right let me
start with the games last night uh what
do you see when you see see Josh Allen
now as opposed to let's say two years
ago three years ago well I see a guy
that I wish had a little bit more help
um I see a guy that hasn't play Superman
every week uh and it's amazing that he's
able to put the cape on over and over
and over again uh it's the nature of the
game today though uh we've talked about
it you and I have talked about it many
times the game's change because the rule
changes and defenses can't launch
anymore there's more space game's more
wide open and so the game is now for a
guy like Josh Allen he is the Prototype
somebody who has a big arm can run
around can run for 52 yard touchdown and
change the game in the biggest games of
the year so I I wish that he could be uh
somebody that had a little bit more help
so he could just play quarterback and
then put the cape on more you know
periodically uh but he's the kind of guy
that's going to win Super Bowls Super
Bowls are going to be won by guys like
that but I think he does have help Steve
I think he has two good tight ends I
agree Dan I I'm with you there's it's
not like he's helpless I just wish
there's a little more running game a
little more ability to just come out of
the Huddle run the play you know get the
get the yards and maybe that's about the
maybe that's about Josh a little bit
maybe it's about him just saying look
I'm gonna I'm gonna be more regular more
of a manager just get the ball out of my
hands make the gains you know let the
let the offense run and be efficient and
that make him even more explosives so I
I look I I I I hear you and I probably
shouldn't have said it as dramatically
but I just I think maybe it's tactics
and I I would love him to be able to run
the football a little bit more who had a
more disappointing season the Cowboys or
the
Eagles uh I you know it's it's it's
painful to think of both uh to watch the
10in one Eagles just go completely
disappear and it was weird even last
night I watched that before the game I'm
like the eagles
will they'll respond and I've said this
week after week and it's like they're
going to respond they they have to
respond and they come up last night and
just there's nothing to respond with and
you are CU what's wrong and uh and so
that's that's uh unnerving if I wear as
an Eagles fan but the thing that but
they're they're not the winner the
Cowboys are the winner or the loser I
guess is that they continue to
underperform at the key moments to their
talent and they've done it for 20 years
and you you you know it never ends they
never live up to or extend or expand on
the talent they have they always have a
talented team but they never lived to it
and last week was just had to be the
most painful thing that Jerry Jones has
seen in 20 years okay but this is
systemic and the one constant has been
Jerry
Jones Dan come on I
mean there's a couple of fundamental
Utah systemic it's fundamental
rootedness of what's wrong with the c
Cowboys and that is that Jerry Jones
runs the team but he's not the coach and
I always said if he's going to run the
team you got to be the coach but he
doesn't hire somebody who is empowered
by Jerry to be independent so that when
you walk in the locker room and you want
to talk to the players you want to yell
at the players and you yell at the
players and the players go well I don't
really care what you say because I only
listen to Jerry and that's the problem
is that the head coach for 20 years has
not been
empowered and he's got to hire somebody
who is clearly empowered they talk about
Bill belich right now it's fun to talk
about I don't know if there's any chance
of it but a guy like that that would be
somebody who now has the power in the
locker room and can get the players to
play and to be and live live up to the
expectations and to their talent now the
other piece of it though is because it's
America's team everyone talks about it
that somehow you're already you're
capable you're already famous and
because of that they don't have they
haven't earned it I I think what they
should do is like you don't get the star
there's two stars on your helmet you get
one star when you win 10 games and you
get another star when you win a playoff
game and that's how you earn the chance
to be a cowboy because otherwise you put
the helmet on and everyone thinks
they're famous and they get punched in
the mouth and like wait we're we're
already we're great what are you talking
about we're we're the Cowboys and you
see that over and over and over again so
those are the two rooted pieces that
need to change or else the Cowboys
continue and people can argue with me oh
Steve that's not true well 20 years of
it 30 years of it you have to start
saying there's something systemic about
it and you got to empower a coach and
you got to take the Stars off the helmet
until they get earned yeah I think it's
a great point because there's a sense of
entitlement and and you're right you're
100% yeah you're a cowboy so you're
actually saying you start the season
with no stars on your helmet either side
100% because it says it's just where
they that's who that's the situation
it's not I'm not blame there's no blame
it's just the truth and so that you have
to go they have to go earn that that
ability to be a cowboy because otherwise
it gets given too easily without having
there you know it it just they think
that they just show up and everyone goes
oh they the Cowboys like you know the
problem is that the wrest League doesn't
care
anymore doesn't seem to matter I want
you to place Bill bellich where would
you put him oh it's a tough one because
he's just it
he and you wonder if he needs the
support of all you know some Co like can
he bring a bunch of people with him and
then how long is he going to be there um
because you want it today's game today's
game's different you look at the most
Innovative minds of the game today and
you're looking at uh Miami you're
looking at Kansas City you're looking at
San Francisco LA the Vikings the the the
Packers like the Innovative minds are
really the guys that are moving around
taking advantage of the space and so
bill belich is an amazing coach but in
today's game he's going to have to find
that offensive coordinator which he
hasn't had for a number of years who can
be that Innovative mind because that's
who's winning that that's how you win
champ used to be I'll make a ferocious
defense and I'll carry a team to the
Super Bowl you can't do that anymore
it's an it's an offensive game it's a
wideopen Innovative game and it's also
run by that guy there's maybe eight
today and if Jordan love is now one of
them out of nowhere or CJ strout is
amazing if those guys can are obviously
emerging then you've got eight to 10
guys in the league that can go win a
championship you got 20 teams that
literally are watching Dan they have no
chance they're just showing up playing
six 17 games and then waving goodbye and
so there's eight to 10 teams that have a
shot and if you know if you're gonna
Place Bill bich you're have to place him
in one of those teams with one of those
guys with an offensive locator who's
Innovative and so really to me that's
more important than the actual
geography would you replace him in
Dallas would you put him in there for
Mike McCarthy well for look you and I
would both agree that systemically that
would be a positive right that nobody
would wonder if Jerry Jones or Bill bich
in control and I think that's important
whoever that is needs to be able to walk
in the locker room and leave Jerry
behind and I think Jerry should Empower
that and and embrace that but does Jerry
know that he's part of the problem Steve
that's that's part of the problem
because you have to read the room but D
I've been tell look she obviously
doesn't listen to me cuz I've been
saying it for 20 years so it like yeah
but you don't tell him this when you see
him in person when you're in no I have I
have intimated some of this to him when
I see him like Jerry okay okay hold on
I'm I'm Jerry Jones and I say hey Steve
how are you how you doing how you doing
J you've got to get a coach that's
empowered that walks in the locker room
is not AF you know and he's like yeah
that's not intimating that's telling
him I mentioned it okay I've mentioned
it number of times uh Hall of Famer
Steve Young joining us on the program
how did the ners not make it to the
Super Bowl uh you saw them get beat um
by the
Ravens uh and and a bully defense the
Cleveland Browns did that um and you
also saw them get beat by the Bengals
with Joe burrow just throwing it all
over the field um and there's those are
the two things you know you have and
who's got a defense that's got that
bully defense in the NFC today I know
they're going to probably see the Lions
and the Packers I don't know that either
on the road can can do that who can
throw it around can Jordan love repeat
this can he be the new Patrick Mahomes
Josh Allen uh Lamar Jackson you know can
he be that guy because if he can he can
throw it all over the field there is
some weakness in the secondary that
shows up and you know they can get beat
uh and it's been proven that way I don't
think either defense in the NFC can can
be the the bullies that that could slow
them down you got to be honest it's
pretty unlikely that the 49ers get beat
who do you think's the best quarterback
of all
time you like sit in the bar stool and
you know gonna get in a fight over the
stupid stuff look Tom Brady has seven
Super Bowls Joe had four I mean you just
when he had a seven Super Bowl you're
like no one's going to ever and no one
says there's going to be another person
that wins Seven Super Bowls I I I
you you never say never but I say never
no one will ever win seven super bowls
and so to me it we tend to just say that
if you w Whoever has the most Super
Bowls is the greatest of all time and
that's fine you can have all kinds of
arguments about it and and scream and
yell but until somebody wins another six
or seven Super Bowls you know Tom Brady
I mean it just has to be that way okay
but do you truly believe that that
should be the bottom line if you're
going to find never it never is but
Steve we don't hold other positional
players to that yeah it's contextual of
course but that's Dan you oh now you're
going to be I'm I'm I'm upset that
that's the the parameters that we're
going to make the judgment on so I want
to change the the way that that's done
well good luck you're going to be run
over like okay let's think about let's
look at um contextually around the
players that uh H you know had more uh
um uh comebacks fourth quarter comebacks
but then like wait if you have a lot of
fourth quarter comebacks what are you
doing behind well who had the most uh
you know like it just you'll run out of
space I think in the end uh football's a
team game so quarterback's the ultimate
player on the team game and so the
ultimate thing to do is to go to the
Super Bowl on the team game and the
quarterback who does it the most I mean
I I I think that's probably why it wins
Dan because it's the one that there's a
lot of other ways to cut it but in the
end you know championships have a
championships have a way of like calming
the water will somebody be recognized as
a better receiver than Jerry Rice In Our
Lifetime no I think he just
relentlessly
um he just you you can't match the
numbers people have tried uh even in
today's what's crazy is The Game's
changed so much it's so much more wide
open you're seeing efficiency records in
the 18s 120s you're seeing uh yardage
touchdowns you know um if you look at
eror adjusted you know you think that
Jerry Rice would easily be covered by
now right come on I mean 20 30 years
later you're still looking up like
pretty pretty dramatically at Jerry Rice
then you ask yourself how because even
if you're GNA be ER adjusted and still
be dominant and even uner adjusted still
be
dominant you're going to dominate for a
long time
when you watch the game now with your
kids like do you do you ever go how did
I play that
game like how did I survive I've done
that when I you know on Monday nights
when we're on the sideline and uh you
know some teams are particularly kind of
bully looking and you w and you and you
I watch the first quarter a lot from the
sidelines and I'll be with a buddy or
something he's like you you freaking
played
this this he calls it this played this I
played this it wasn't just patty cake
man this is this is this is he goes
you're kidding me like you get freaking
rocked man you you're not gonna so yeah
I do I time goes on and you think about
the game but I still I the problem with
me Dan is I see the game today and I see
the players that are thriving in this
game today the guys they're my guys guys
that played like I played and and you
see how they treat the quarterback and
you see all the open space and the the
flats are never open the middle of the
field is unpatrolled and you're like
please let me play again please let me
play in this time and I and I really
mean that like I would love so
desperately to play today it would be so
much fun I mean I never thought football
is necessarily fun I thought it
rewarding and challenging and like
engaging but I never thought of it as
like fun and I for whatever reason
today's game to me is like oh so much
fun I just want to play who's the former
teammate of yours who should be a Hall
of
Famer uh well there's two there's
probably Roger Craig and and and Brent
Jones okay and and I think you'd argue
for Harris Barton like all we talk about
20 years of you know dominance uh what
18 playoff appearances in a row or 19
playoff and appearances in a row five
five Super Bowls in what 12 Championship
Games 13 championship games I mean it
was it was it was Patriot likee and so
and the guys that led that and did that
you're you're forgetting a couple or
three um inevitably that happens but
that's that's how I would line it up do
you have anything cool in your office is
that your actual office where you are
look I look I my when I got married my
wife says hey look there's only one
quarterback on the in the family that's
me
wait what are you talking
about you see ring Steve the other
quarterback bought the house you see my
R I got my rings here so I I I've lived
uh for no for a few decades r
recognizing at a home this is not myice
this is my wife's office I have a little
corner that I'm using kind I'm I'm
before the uh office hours and so I get
to sit here a while what happened to
you I can tell you one thing offensive
line sucks I can tell you
that that's because that's what I'm
playing now and
uh great to talk to you uh thank you
thanks for sharing Steve you're the best
Steve Young Hall of
Famer